if you've memorized pi to 15 places
congratulations you're a great big
racist
great rhyme yep the war on timetables
and division is the new le is the left's
new crazed religion we've seen it again
and again headlines declaring that math
is bigoted that solving for x leaves
them asking why
true the workstars d modern math guilty
of a white patriarchal past especially
those pesky arabic numerals
arabic yeah and now it's taken over
bates college the private liberal arts
school in maine aren't they all wants to
revamp math courses to focus on
colonialism and privilege but not the
kind of privilege that lets you waste 78
000 a year in tuition of course
according to the college fix which
obtained a copy of the proposed
curriculum change a group of professors
and students suggest courses like
calculus could situate race white
supremacy colonialism power and
privilege centrally throughout the
course wow i haven't encountered this
much poppycock since i stumbled onto
that nude beach for seniors
but if this change is adopted
the glass the classes would be mandatory
one of the courses is called mathematics
for social justice insane i wonder what
that would look like
hello everyone welcome i'm kyle st
croissant professor of numbers please
take your seats which have been
prioritized based on race gender
identity and level of body positivity as
you know the waitlist for this class is
a mile long frankly you're lucky to find
an open chair
now pythagoras
isaac newton albert einstein all
mathematicians bigots did you know that
the apple that hit newton on the head
was picked by a migrant worker
yeah look if you don't think math is
going to impact your life just wait
until your wife takes half of your sh
sorry mr croissant doctor
doctor
uh isn't math kind of the universal
constant that unites everybody
regardless of geographical or political
affiliation
well dylan i think i've got a problem
for you that you're really gonna love
two plus two equals get the
out of my class you sis white homophobe
i literally have black panther on my
notebook he's my favorite
i think that's enough for today next
week we'll discuss why the nazis
invented calculus
oh look at you
jamie you're a racist
[Laughter]
is
mathematics uh uh like an emblem of
white supremacy i don't think so no this
is the first time i'm hearing of it
um
the world i think the vulgar thing is
getting a little bit out of control yeah
uh when i was in college i wasn't even
woke for most of my early classes
and um
i don't know it's just how is this gonna
even end when i did take calculus though
i think we all were taking calculus
going god i wish this was more
complicated with more variables
but how's this even going to work how
would they integrate this they're going
to be like oh a train's going 50 miles
an hour the train is being driven
northbound it's driven by a cis white
male
and then the southbound train is going
nine miles an hour i have an answer why
don't you check the train schedule
i'll answer all your questions
so kat um it's like when you say math is
racist it's like saying a specific
language is racist because you don't
understand it but math is a universal
language anybody can do it
right but you
i can do some math but i don't need it
because of my charm and brilliance in
other areas yes
and iphone calculated yes
thank you for about thank you thank you
um but this is the conclusion or
probably not i'll probably get worse of
something where
if you disagree you're a racist is built
into it right someone could be in that
meeting like um i think math class
should be about math like yeah you
should be able to say that but you can't
in this situation because then they'll
say oh that's your you know your
privilege it doesn't matter if you're
white or not because you can be a white
supremacist even if you're not a white
person yeah that's true that's true uh
walter this is what i think
shellenberger who we had on last night i
think it's he called it second-degree
racism where you decide that a specific
group can't handle something that
everybody else can handle so by looking
out for them you're the bigot does that
make sense
it does but you know i i want to use my
oxford education for once on this show
what these people don't realize is that
they're wrong in their own terms
our number system the arabic numeral
system was invented by people of color
right it was invented by them it is
their greatest accomplishment and yet
they have no memory for it uh yeah i
mean half of these things that we say
are racist or blame on white people were
actually stolen by white people from
other people so uh
you know here's to arabic numerals and
to the number zero which they invented
yes my favorite
number um
emily what what what do you have to say
well
this entire thing
is an illustration of what we are going
through socially in this entire country
bates college has 2 000 students
you pay 80 grand to go there and this
working group consisted of five
professors and five students three of
whom were freshmen they're 17. they're
absolutely ridiculous to your point
earlier where ignorant people are in
school because they're getting educated
students are ridiculous and yet people
are listening to them to me that's a
microcosm what we're seeing right now
it's one loud person on twitter that
shouts a ridiculous woke thing this
person is canceled this person is racist
this is what should be and then
everyone's like oh yes absolutely it's
the emperor's new clothes the emperor's
no clothes yeah don't actually nude
they're just scared of getting canceled
too exactly they're scared of loud 17
year old great just real quick similar
to walter i went to oxford community
college
i like i like math that makes sense i
don't like i think i just get rid of
calculus so i just miss i want math that
can be useful in regular life you know
like math like say there's 13 of us you
know and we have a 12 pack of beer yeah
you got to figure it out right 12 of you
need to leave
because
[Applause]
perfect
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else